quick what is the first spell that comes
to mind when you think of the old school
Harry Potter video games here maybe this
will help
[Music]
so where did this charming but simple
spell also known as the knockback Jinx
even come from the actual incantation
flopindo first appeared in the Harry
Potter and the Philosopher's Stone video
game in November of 2001. it's actually
possible it was used by both Lupine and
Snape in the original book series but
more on that in a bit in today's video
we're going to take a look at the
history of flippindo where it came from
and should it be considered as part of
the Harry Potter Canon of course it's by
far one of the most memorable spells
among fans of the video games and has
appeared numerous times since its first
appearance in 2001. in fact it even
appears in Harry Potter Hogwarts mystery
a mobile title from Jam City that
originally released in 2018. Harry
Potter Hogwarts mystery is still being
actively supported today and I'd like to
thank Jam City for kindly sponsoring
today's video in Harry Potter Hogwarts
mystery you can customize your own
character choose your house and live out
magical moments as a student at Hogwarts
I'm hosting my own sweepstakes and you
can win a 25 Amazon gift card so stick
around to find out how to to win in
Harry Potter Hogwarts mystery you have
the freedom to create a custom character
that feels like you with a wide range of
diverse hairstyles and outfits to unlock
of course you guys already know my
favorite house is Gryffindor I've always
had that strong bond with the trio of
Harry Ron Hermione and The Bravery this
house represents you'll get to interact
with Professor McGonagall as your head
of house and because of the time period
you'll also get to interact with your
favorite characters from the movies and
books like Dumbledore McGonagall Snape
the Weasley twins Dobby and even my
favorite magical creatures from the
Fantastic Beasts films so to win that 25
Amazon gift card all you have to do is
download Harry Potter Hogwarts mystery
using my affiliate Link in the
description below then screenshot your
character getting sorted and to let me
know which house you get tag me over on
Twitter at retro raconteur and I'll be
selecting a random person from those who
reach out and tag me to receive a 25
Amazon gift card now if we manage to hit
200 downloads I'll give away an
additional 25 gift card to another
random entry once again thanks to Jam
City for very kindly sponsoring today's
video as for the history of flippindo
we'll First Look to those who made the
game no wonder developed the title for
PC and who better to ask than one of
those who actually worked on the title
that's exactly what fellow YouTuber
flandrew did when he reached out to one
of the designers who worked on
philosopher's stone for the PC Christo
Wichita spoke with flandrew and told him
that all of the Spells were in fact
provided to them by JK Rowling they
actually had a special book just for
them that was considered Top Secret at
the time this book essentially became
their spell catalog and they were only
allowed to use the specific spells that
were provided Rowling had given them
five that could be used by Harry in-ear
1 and they ended up using all five of
them
I don't know
Wingardium Leviosa incendio
Wichita said the definitions provided
were very loose and that Rowling
understood the need for the developers
to have a little bit of freedom in
interpreting the use of each spell
lupindo's definition was rather simple
in that it was a spell meant to push
something so if the Spells came from
Rolling are they automatically
considered Harry Potter Canon first off
what does Canon even mean exactly
especially years after the original
books and now that we've seen numerous
video games movies a stage play and more
what even is Canon you might be
surprised to see that even if we start
with a book definition it doesn't
immediately make things more clear
Merriam-Webster actually has five
definitions of the word and most of them
are relating to religious questions and
in fact three of these definitions
contain even more than one explanation
for the World of Harry Potter it
probably makes the most sense to start
with this option here the authentic
works of a writer or possibly the
additional section here which adds a
sanctioned or accepted group or body of
related Works truth be told Canon is
actually pretty subjective But
ultimately it all has to start with the
original Creator the Harry Potter
lexicon has been chronicling The
Wizarding World for more than 20 years
and has long been considered a reliable
source among fans they stayed on their
website that they have always focused
only on what Rowling herself created
thus their definition of Canon is as
follows information which has come
directly from JK Rowling in either
written or spoken form is considered
Canon all other sources including the
film version for Warner Brothers are not
considered official or Canon although
some information from them is included
in the Lexicon if it can be verified as
coming from Rolling herself they then
break things up into four categories
primary Canon secondary Canon other
writings by Rolling and finally tertiary
Cannon primary Cannon comes purely from
the seven books of the original series
and nothing else secondary Canon adds
other Wizarding World books written by
Rolling two of these book of spells and
book of potions were augmented reality
video games for the PlayStation 3 which
took advantage of the PlayStation move
controller other writings by Rolling the
Lexicon takes into account for can
Cannon are the original version of her
website her current website her Twitter
feed and Pottermore which is now known
as wizardingworld.com and lastly there's
tertiary Canon which gets into a whole
host of other details that may be
considered Canon such as online chats
interviews and more so the logical
starting place for fulpindo is to find
out was it written by JK Rowling
according to Wichita and others who
worked on the game the answer is yes
which is probably why the Lexicon does
include it in their list for the Spells
of the series now even though the spell
first appeared by name in the video
games it's also possible we saw it in
the original books as well but just
didn't know the name or perhaps Rowling
hadn't decided on a name yet you see in
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
Harry and Lupine get into an argument
that results in Lupine hitting Harry
with a spell that caused a loud bang
Harry felt as if he'd been punched
backwards into the wall of course it
wasn't a spell that injured Harry
severely so something rather tame like
fulpindo would make sense here Snape
also used a similar spell that knocked
Harry to the ground and made a loud bang
as well as he fled Hogwarts at the end
of Half-Blood Prince both of these were
cast non-verbally and with flippindo
being such a basic spell to learn it
would make perfect sense for both Lupine
and Snape to be more than capable of
casting it non-verbally which of course
is more difficult to channel without the
incantation it would have been no
problem whatsoever for talented Wizards
like Lupine and Snape not to mention
that they both truly did not want to
harm Harry the Lexicon also mentions
that fulpindo once appeared in the
Pottermore dueling club and that it's
also used by Draco Malfoy against Harry
and Harry Potter and the cursed child
but even with its other appearances
fulpindo will always be known as a video
game spell in the original games it
served as a basic form of defense for
Harry and was even used extensively in
the final battle against Voldemort at
the end of Philosopher's Stone it was
also used frequently in the game's
puzzles as far as the original movie
tie-in games go flippindo would only
appear in the first three from Goblet of
Fire on different spells were introduced
looking back at the whole history of
Harry Potter video games is actually
pretty fascinating if you'd like for a
more in-depth look at the complete
history of the Harry Potter video games
then you should definitely check out the
video on the right side of your screen
now as I break it all down there as
always thank you both so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon